this is really great joe biden is
immediately handling the pandemic and
all of these different things
donald trump is in court trying to get
rid of obamacare and yesterday joe biden
and kamala harris held a press
conference and they said
we we should not be ending obamacare at
this point in time
now before we even get to any clips it
was sort of
jarring to see joe and kamala go a half
hour
without insulting anybody and when they
took questions
joe biden actually answered the
questions it was a nice change of pace
i've just become completely unaccustomed
to it over the last four years
now when joe biden was asked questions
it's crazy that this is even noteworthy
he would listen to the question pause
to think about an answer and then
actually answer the question
mind blown right incredible and as you
can imagine
most of the questions joe biden was
asked were about the fact that trump
continues to claim he won
and that biden didn't win and trump
hasn't conceded and joe biden played it
really well
here he is answering and laughing trump
off and i'll tell you about the
importance of that in a moment
presumably at some point you will need
access to more classified information
to secure facilities and the like what
options
are you considering how will you move
ahead if the president continues to
refuse to concede
well look uh access
to classified information is uh
is useful uh but i'm not a position to
make any decisions
on those issues anyway there's one as i
said one president at a time
and he will be president until january
20th
it would be nice to have it but it's not
critical and uh
that's so we're just going to proceed
the way we have we're going to
we're going to do exactly what we'll be
doing if he had conceded
and said we've won which we have
and so there's nothing really changing
but not ruling out legal action
no i don't see a need for a big election
uh quite frankly
i think the legal action is uh you're
seeing it
play out the actions he's taking and so
far
there is no evidence of any of the
assertions made
by the president or secretary of state
pompeo
[Laughter]
secretary of state pompeo so
the calm is commendable and the laugh at
the end is just perfect as far as optics
go
but what is really interesting to
understand
is that as the narcissistic egomaniac
that is donald trump
narcissistic egomaniacs want other
people to be
mad and they want other people to be
afraid we've talked to
all sorts of different psychologists and
others
on the program over the last four years
and they have explained and this is
widely
written about in literature um in
psychology literature
that narcissists and these sort of
egomaniacs like donald trump
they control situations
by getting the other person angry by
getting the other person
rattled and so joe biden just laughing
it off
and moving full steam ahead with the
transition
and a coronavirus task force and the
some of the same reporters who normally
would be sitting in the press briefing
room asking trump questions
are now at joe biden's press conference
this
has to be enraging donald trump now joe
biden was asked versions of that same
question including does what donald
trump is doing
hurt your transition plan does what
donald trump is doing affect your
ability to do abc
and joe biden just very calmly saying
we're moving ahead
donald trump's behavior is not affecting
my transition i'm the president-elect
i'm moving forward
thank you mr president-elect during the
campaign
you said you were not naive about how
difficult it would be to
unite the country it's now three days
after
you were projected as the
president-elect the
president himself says he has won this
election his own administration has not
moved forward to give you access to what
you need to do to begin
the work of your transition just a few
minutes ago the secretary of state when
asked if he would
cooperate with a smooth transition he
said there will be a smooth transition
to a second
trump administration i wonder if you
have a message for the president who may
well be watching right now
and how do you expect to be able to work
with republicans when so many
have thus far refused to even
acknowledge your victory well first of
all
uh we are already beginning
the transition we're well underway and
uh
the ability uh for uh the administration
in any way by failure to recognize this
as our win uh does not
uh change the dynamic at all and what
we're able to do and then joe biden
interestingly pointed out that he thinks
republicans are standing by trump
because they're scared or intimidated by
him and there's a lot of interesting
stuff
to discuss there as well
mr president-elect senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell has suggested
today that he may not recognize
the outcome of this election until the
electoral college meets
next month have you spoken to your
longtime
friend in the senate mr mcconnell and
what do you make of his specific
comments over the last 24 hours
i haven't had a chance to speak to mitch
my expectation is that i will
do that not too distant future um
i think that uh the whole republican
party has been put in a position with a
few notable exceptions
of uh
being mildly intimidated by the
sitting present yeah what's interesting
about that and our friend bill share and
others have been tweeting about this
it is very interesting that even as a
loser
republicans still seem to be under the
thumb of donald trump now this could be
for a few different reasons there could
be republicans who still think
maybe trump gets another four years and
so i should sort of stay on his good
side
it could be that it's merely concern
over the georgia senate races
and once those are done they will bail
on trump now of course at that point
it'll only be 15 days until trump leaves
office
i don't know we streamed this event live
and many of our viewers reacted to
biden's calm by saying
biden being calm is making me calm when
trump is manic and going crazy
my blood pressure goes up this is a lot
of our viewers biden being so calm is
making me calm which is interesting
and then lastly here's joe biden making
the point that trump not conceding
makes trump look bad and bringing up the
the idea of trump's
legacy
sir what do you say to the americans
that are anxious over the fact that
president trump has yet
to concede and what that might mean for
the country well
um i just think it's an embarrassment um
quite frankly uh the only thing that
how can i say this tactfully i think it
will not help the president's legacy
i think that i know from my discussions
with foreign leaders thus far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and
endured given how donald trump has been
behaving
it would actually be completely
appropriate for joe biden
to attack donald trump and it would be
totally appropriate for joe biden to go
after donald trump
in a more serious way and yet he didn't
we are not going to agree with joe biden
on policy
on nearly everything but there is a
change in the air since joe biden was
declared president-elect by networks
it's been palpable and even many who did
not vote for biden in the primary
but ultimately did vote for joe biden in
in the
general election with some skepticism
have emailed me and said you know
it's not about policy right now i'm
finding joe's
demeanor in the face of unhinged
insanity from trump
and endless conspiracy theories from the
right i'm finding joe biden's demeanor
to be the right fit
for the time let's hope it continues and
we have so much more to talk about today
about the conspiracy theories and the
allegations and so much more
uh including secretary of state mike
pompeo
asked about the fact that there's been
no acknowledgement of joe biden's win
mike pompeo saying there will be a
smooth transition
to a second trump administration that's
coming up a little bit later
make sure you're following me on twitter
where you can find me
at d pacman if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video